look it's hard enough to have a kit sure
but then when you're co-parenting yes so
you're not obviously married anymore
you're divorced so you're single and
you're uh you know you're you got work
you get a podcast you got you know
auditions you got whatever roles you're
doing and you're taking care of your
daughter how do you how do you do that I
I couldn't I could I don't know if I
could do that well you don't even you
don't have kids I I don't have a child
you have two dogs I have two dogs as of
now as of now do you want kids I I don't
think so I mean I don't know I mean look
at the woman I'm with and I fall in love
with her and she's like I I it feels
right maybe I'd consider but it's not
like a big thing for you that you've
always known you've wanted I think I did
and I think that time kind of has passed
yeah it doesn't really work that way so
if you notice that two times a week oh
yeah I know that's not there can you
well
yeah no not so good I had braces and it
took it away from me my daughter's an
excellent Whistler really yeah I can't
do that good for her I know um but the
co-parents the co-parents yeah it's just
you know
uh having a kid definitely every day of
your life you're like okay my kid's
alive you know seriously no like you
have these morbid thoughts of like all
the things that could happen and that
adds to the new found anxiety that comes
along with being older and raising a kid
and everybody like oh my God like they
could be crossing the street you see all
the the [__] news like everything
that they put out there it's always the
most horrendous story I don't watch it
anymore well yeah I don't watch it but
like on Instagram or whatever it is like
you're scrolling yeah that's all and
it's all like this person died because
they were walking across the street or
like you know and it's all of that so it
just keeps feeding your [__] mind
with this awful you know all these
stories I'm like where's the where are
the positive ones and it puts it in your
head so I'm constantly like oh [__] this
could happen and like there's nothing
more important in the world than your
child when you have one so it's just
becomes everything is way more
heightened because you're you have this
person that you're responsible for but
is it hard to just deal with the other
person and their schedules and they're
like you're not together anymore so is
it kind of weird have you gotten past
that yeah no we do really well well
that's good because a lot of people
don't right it's all it's all
circumstantial it's all different you
know situations and whatnot so we do
really well and my daughter knows
nothing but love and you know and that's
the most important thing you know yeah
so scheduling is whatever but you figure
it out you figure it out but she is so
loved by both of us and you know that's
all that's all you really need to do
that's the number one thing I always say
that it's just like you know I I you do
love scary movies sorry I was just
looking around it's just kind of a
little thing I don't always watch them
yeah I do but there's a lot there's a
lot of them yeah it's either
documentaries what's your favorite scary
movie I'm calling them scary movies I
mean probably I always say The Shining
it just it's just directed like
everything that moves it's just that
they don't make them like that anymore
no but there's a lot of good ones if you
ever do you watch them sometimes the
only ones like I can stay awake for at
night okay well I have some that are
quality let me give you a list that you
can avoid all the [__] that's out there
that Gets applauded By Rotten Tomatoes
which I have a thing for yeah
everything's 99 well yeah are they
getting paid well I mean I'm how could
you say this [__] is so good when you
watch it you're like yeah that was like
a 63. oh so you don't agree with rotten
I do not agree with Rotten Tomatoes I
think they get changed I think that
somebody pays them I think the Studios
have deals oh there's something there's
something going on I could see that yeah
I do I do yeah and it's like the big
critic the big critics and all that I
that's how I feel you think and I think
it's kind of skewed now because the
whole world is just in a different way
so like oh that person let's
let's give them a high score
without saying too much sure